en katmandú la capital de nepal una
víctima de trabajo forzoso del mundial
da su testimonio
este era mi permiso de trabajo para
acatar
trabajó durante más de un año en la
construcción del metro en ocasiones tuve
que trabajar a 45 e incluso 55 grados
centígrados teníamos que trabajar
incluso cuando estábamos enfermos los
trabajadores no cualificados los
nepalíes dicen que son los más
maltratados en las obras
a 3000 kilómetros de nepal en doha uno
de nuestros periodistas fue invitado a
visitar un campamento de trabajadores
llevo aquí desde 2016 y estamos en 2022
puedo decir que hay muchas mejoras en
materia de derechos humanos y derechos
laborales
según the Guardian al menos 6.500
trabajadores migrantes han muerto en
Qatar desde el inicio de las obras las
autoridades cataríes dicen que solo han
contabilizado 37 y cuántos nepalíes
en 2015 un equipo de fans televisión
filmó estas imágenes en el aeropuerto de
katmandú cada semana aterrizaban aviones
procedentes de Qatar con los restos de
los trabajadores nepalíes a bordo en el
sur del país en la región más pobre de
nepal hay decenas de familias
desconsoladas
mi hermana yandra perdió a su marido en
2019 diez meses después de su llegada a
Qatar El joven de 27 años era trabajador
de la construcción en un estadio
su certificado de defunción dice que
murió de causas naturales pero la viuda
nunca recibió un certificado de autopsia
no entiendo mi marido era fuerte a Quién
nepal construyó casas según las
autoridades nepalíes 180 de sus
nacionales han muerto cada año en Qatar
desde que se concedió la copa del mundo